now let's have a go I do remember I said
to you before sometimes it even doesn't
look like it's going to make much of
difference it helps to let your integral
equal something just makes it a little
easier simpler to a manipulator so I'm
gonna call that capital I you don't have
to it will just make another more
straightforward integration by parts for
this question what's the first thing we
have to do I have to split it in some
way I have to select right so what did
you pick is you know you can choose
either country doesn't matter sometimes
remember I showed you an example where
it sort of blew up right where you chose
it wrong and what you ended up with as a
result from this was worse off okay
other times not that big a deal okay now
I think from my working I went with this
okay so if you did it differently why
don't you follow along and see how it
diverges and how it ends up being the
same okay now that's you what's the
audience rough game do you nd X is equal
to if this is what I've chosen it's just
e to the X isn't it
okay so I continue my way around the box
I need my DV okay which was you signed
so what's V what's the primitive
what's the primitive side negative cause
I can't let's put this thing together
this is equal to you just read down the
one column right so I'm gonna get
negative e to the X cos x and then you
go this way right so now I want to
subtract the integral off now I've got a
double negative here right so I'm gonna
turn that into a plus e to the X cos x
DX did I choose it wrong now I mean you
might you may well conclude that I have
chosen wrong okay
however often you will run into this
problem that no matter which way you
choose you end up with something in your
like blue okay
now the thing is though have a look at
this this is another product right
I can I can work with this I can work
with this so I'm gonna take that maybe
I'll put it off onto the side okay the
integral of e to the X cos x with
respect to X ok now I can do exactly
what I did before right can't I can't I
break it up in this way how would you
break it up you can do it almost
identical
couldn't you okay instead of it I'm
gonna go e to the X again which means e
to the X again but I'm not I don't have
sine X as my other factor I have cause
so what's the primitive of cause it's
sign
regular sorry okay so therefore what I'm
gonna get here is e to the X sine X
minus v2 you write sine X e to the X now
at this point you may want wonder if
I've done something wrong I look I feel
like I've gone in circles okay because I
come back to the
general integral right but this is okay
the universe is not exploded yet and the
reason why believe it or not is that -
oh that - science saves the world watch
okay now this is why it was easy to call
it I or helpful to call it okay this is
e to the X sine X - whatever that
integral was you okay with that so now
I'm going to take that result and stick
it in here where I needed that integral
okay so I have I equal to negative index
cos x plus this stuff - I look at my
signs right yeah I think so okay now can
you see why the negative is so important
you see what difference it makes that I
I can move it around just like any other
integral right so if I move it over this
side I'm gonna get to hi equals this
I'll rearrange it so I have my negative
in the go see what I've done and now I
want capital I right so I'm just gonna
divide by 2 I might as well take out
this factor while I'm at it
okay settle right
Oh constant thank you so there's a
couple things to note for note there
right firstly just to help yourself
let the eat into Greek or something
secondly do not be deterred when you see
another integral often you'll just have
to integrate my part again okay